I'm evil ah they take their dad from
Tripoli central hospital for burial
[Music]
and it's here that Colonel Gadhafi's
only adopted daughter supposedly killed
25 years ago worked as a surgeon
Hannah Gaddafi was just a baby when
Colonel Gaddafi claimed she'd been
struck by a US missile at his Bab
al-azizia compound in 1986 u.s. cluster
bombs kept by the dictator as a monument
Hanna's death though was a pretense and
a lie kept up by Gaddafi for years when
rebels broke into the compound last week
they found Hannah's Passport Hannah was
very much alive and well and by her
father's side so where is she now
well he was the last fighting on my team
of hours she was in the hospital and
then she disappeared I'm sure she's with
your father because we knew that she has
but very special ratio the hell father
and I heard from some people in the
security the only person can go to her
father without any formalities others
even her children when you go you have
to go to the point that's also what she
can go without an appointment
whenever he moves she with him for those
who train to be doctors with Hannah it
was an open secret in Libya but not
beyond and her office in the hospital
matched her status I don't know that she
is live here in office like that I I
supposed to say that it's not an office
it's home and the hospital tending his
sister also a doctor believed to have
been deliberately shot by Gaddafi's
forces for treating rebels Ziad Kennedy
says she was a bully she was controlling
everything she was moving the guys she
was controlling completely the hospital
liked what she liked I mean she was one
of the her family for doctor biruni
celebrating the holy festival of Eid the
lie about Hannah comes as no surprise
what do you think if Colonel Gaddafi
then and his family what do you think
about it after all killing and
destroying what I think about it is he
different he's the devil yes it's quite
clear nobody kills his people
dr. biruni has doubts too about the
death of Gaddafi's son is safe Alvaro
supposedly killed along with his own
children by a NATO airstrike in April
uncovering the truth about this regime
will take time